the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
and k for karate
[Music]
from the executive producer of jaden son
and three huge daniel stans
comes a show they got everything right
about making a new tv
franchise except for launching it on
youtube red
goodbye fallen soldier turns out there
are losers in this dojo
cobra kai prepare for the story of what
happens after the triumphant freeze
frame ending
of your favorite 80s movie in a premise
that sounds like it has just enough gas
to power a funny or die sketch
but is actually good enough to fuel
multiple seasons and now that the saved
by the bell sequel is off to a fun star
too
we're back on board with the last scraps
of pop culture being strip mined and fed
back to us by telecoms and streaming
giants
hey is jude nelson still alive let's
crank out six steps of old man bender
they can fight the robot from short
circuit
i mean good return to the atlanta area
of the san fernando valley
and follow a washed up guy who's out to
prove that there's more to him than one
thing he did in the 80s
william zepka i mean johnny lawrence
it turns out he got crank kicked so hard
his entire life collapsed
ultimately turning him into a booze
hound with a two-word vocabulary
cobra like the badass snake and you're
being a cobra kai
is about being badass don't be a what
it's badass
lightbeard is from truckasaurus was
badass those are
moves kicking is badass drowning is for
all right don't be afraid
who's so stuck in the past you'll start
to wonder if that kick
actually put him into a waking coma for
one of those hashbrowns at the end you
know like hash brown team cobra kai or
something www
period cobra kai period com i'll lower
case
this concussion nonsense uh you might
want to rethink that last one on frozen
caveman sensei that's a facebook
wow but no former antagonist reframed as
a protagonist is complete
without his former protagonist refrain
as an antagonist frenemy
enter daniel larusso the karate kid who
definitely stopped practicing karate
but never gave up on his asian fetish
the yanagi or yanagiba
depending on the region is a knife used
exclusively
for cutting sashimi this guy definitely
has a waifu pillow when cobra kai
rises again he'll defend his version of
the martial art
a boring hybrid of tours in therapy that
only works by accident once you've
tricked a teenager into jacking it for
you
mr miyagi would be so proud if you just
stopped talking about him for once in
your adult life
mr miyagi had to teach me only mr miyagi
could do it mr miyagi didn't want me to
compete anymore i wish you were here to
give me some of that miyagi wisdom right
now
mr miyagi took me to this beautiful lake
up north to train mr miyagi built this a
few years before he died mr miyagi
treated me like a son
not a foreigner that was mr miyagi's
favorite song mr miyagi
i mean you're such a great teacher
please stop talking about the old man
you were best friends with in high
school
but this show isn't just about old
karate kids
it's also about the next karate kids
sorry the next next karate kids
no and that was kung fu stupid movie
these karate kids miguel whose decision
to learn karate brings him confidence
and gets him paralyzed so wow that got
dark fast
daniel's daughter sam who grew up doing
martial arts
okay sure aisha the only one with
parents sensible enough to keep her out
of season three
after the fight her parents moved her to
a private school lip slash hawk
the kid who can have exactly one gimmick
at a time
so i'm not supposed to mention his lip
at all leaving early to fix that stupid
haircut
dimitri an insecure nerd with a bright
future in a college improv comedy group
i'm at peace with my depression last
thing i need to be a suicidal
tory the tory of the bunch raymond
a live-action nickelodeon character who
snuck into the show for a season
here 2-4 you can refer to me
as stingray robbie the son that johnny
gave up on
because he could never shut his mouth
literally
[Music]
and anthony the son that danny clearly
gave up on
because even though he lives with him he
could not give less of a [ __ ] about this
little a-hole dad where the hell is my
drink hurry up
you know what i'm gonna throw him in the
goddamn pool okay yeah you know i'd
adopt my rival son to spend less time
around this kid too
sometimes you just have it done in your
hands a trianglish muffin
what is this afghanistan explore a
series where everyone bullies
everyone else and it always leads to
them turning into overnight karate
masters
[Music]
where johnny was bullied by a sensei
danny was bullied by johnny
and johnny was bullied by danny i kicked
his face
i'm just busting your chops so when you
meet some nerds who are getting bullied
by the popular kids
johnny bullies the nerds into learning
karate i see losers i see nerds
see a fat kid with a funny hat with
popping out hey shirt
thanks i'm joking it sucks so the nurse
can use karate to bully the popular kids
who go on to learn karate from the
sensei who bully johnny to believe the
nerds turned popular bullies who bullied
johnny into learning karate in the first
place until johnny's karate is strong
enough to bully him back
did i get that right it's like a vicious
circle shaped like the drum in karate
kid 2
which means bullying is part of balance
because you can't have balance with
quiet
yes sensei so enjoy a battle of good
versus cobra
not seen since dodgeball that's not
exactly prestige television
but is the best around for a
binge-worthy nostalgia trip
that takes all of these 80s archetypes
who can easily settle their differences
with a big karate fight
and treats them like actual characters
with layers in depth
who settled all their differences with a
big karate fight
if it ain't broke right
[Applause]
starring cobra commander
macho man marvel kisses boys nova
immediately
living in a van down by the river
don't talk to me or my dumb son ever
again
richard jewell this cameo brought to you
by seattle's best hawaiian restaurant
kona kitchen let them fight insider
valley references
come visit any of our locations in
tarzana woodland hills north hollywood
for sherman oaks my girlfriend bartends
this place over on kawenga 5am tomorrow
morning
corner of fulton and raymer i worked at
fat cells all summer
i came here well in and out
and then here easter eggs defeat
does not exist in this dojo
what does it do i fixed it for you
[Music]
is that why you brought me here to trick
me into doing karate deep cut easter
eggs
daniel russo was gonna coach
[Applause]
okay holy crap you nerds who wouldn't
even notice that these were easter eggs
hey sam banana ramen chocolate chip
pancakes are up
hey hey
this is miyagi miyagido
[Music]
reasonable solutions to end all this
karate madness calling the police
and take off your shoes
sorry i just had to get that off my
chest breaking board
you know it's a good thing not one
person in the entire valley has taken an
mma class
these kids would all be so screwed
i need to find a way to touch a lot of
people at the same time
strike first strike hard no mercy
the best defense is more
wax on wax off
rest in peace bread venable